well first of all let me just thank
everybody for joining joining me and
joining the team this morning for a
quick update on where we are as you may
have heard and saw last Thursday we
presented to the board the results of
the survey that we put out a you know
really excited that 94 thousand
responses that we receive from not only
our students our parents and community
leaders really sharing some of their
feedback with us you know and as as the
team put together a great report you
know it looks like the majority of our
families want to come back and try to
get back not only to school but our also
that's what we saw from kids parents and
and from the teachers that we you know
that submitted a survey just in
generalities I mean that was a big piece
so one of the things that as I continue
to look at where we are and what we're
going to do obviously as I said publicly
at the board meeting and I continue to
share shared with the State Board of
Education number one factor for us to
come back is obviously the health and
wellness of not only of our students but
also of our children and parents and
staff to make sure that we are safe
following the CDC guidelines as I
committed to this board my school board
of trustees that June 25th that we will
have a plan I'm confident than my team
the team will be able to bring together
the recommendations of where we are
updating or where we are today so I
reviewed a little bit 123 page document
that we're working through now getting
into much more of the details as we
explain to the board when we're looking
at a face to mooches are currently the
phase that we're in the reason that we
selected a face to try to attempt to
start the school years because that will
be the toughest that would be the
toughest for us to be able to implement
we don't know we may go to phase 3 and
phase 4 and come back depending on what
the virus is telling us so what we're
looking at we're now looking and
bringing to the to the board a bottle a
recommendation giving a lot of the
different varieties that are available
for us to
through how do we get kids on a bus how
do we get kids in the school how do we
offer recess how do we provide our
students a high quality education
following the CDC guidelines do we clean
schools before after you know so all of
those details are what we are currently
working and we will be bringing that to
the board June 25th with the
recommendation so a lot of different
moving parts a lot of different pieces
that were trying to figure out now
obviously the number one and the most
important for us the number one and most
important aspect of this is not only in
safety the Wellness but then the
instruction the instruction and how do
we then provide an instructional
opportunity for our students in
elementary middle and high school what I
said you know to the board and what we
what we go back to what I've learned
from the closure to where we are as
decentralized system as we are one of
the things that we are when we do this
and we come back at least have we've had
principals parents teachers
administrators part of our reopening
group one of the things that we are
going to have a plan that is going to be
a virus cleaner plan because it's going
to come out you we're now going to have
the autonomy for some schools to do X
and other schools to do Y so we we've
learned that we have to really provide a
consistent message and they consist in
approach one of the biggest challenges
that I can tell you that we have is that
we don't have any information on the
budget
what will the budget look like for us to
be able to implement so this is where we
continue to have conversations I had a
conversation with the State
Superintendent on Thursday on after the
board meeting on Thursday we met Sunday
all superintendent made we meant this
morning again to really look and pin
down what that looks like we're still
waiting for the executive branch to send
us to give us a better picture on them
on the dollars for for for us for school
year you know so so we're we're planning
but you know really still waiting on the
budget the other piece that we are you
know kind of getting into the time to
open up school you know my
administrators are 11 month
on Friday so time we have to communicate
continue that communication with our
leadership at our schools that we just
can't turn a switch and make a decision
to say here is our principals need time
whatever that looks like they need to
build master schedules they need to be
able to put whatever that system is in
place and we're running out of time and
this is what I said to the board on
Thursday and I'm you know I appreciate
you being here and sending that message
we are running out of time for us to be
able to open up school safely without
some of the details on the numbers so
now I'll turn it over Mauricio for some
questions thanks so much so yeah I'll
just go down the list with folks we'll
start with John Trainor channel 3 Johnny
no question yeah thank you for doing
this superintendent we're obviously
running out of time as you said do you
need that budget and those financial
numbers in order to put a pan in place
or can the school create a plan without
knowing the final budget number well you
know John that's a great question and we
are putting a plan in place because I
can't wait so we're putting a plan in
place we do have a budget right we do
have a budget that our Board adopted but
you know which is you know and we 3738
million dollar projection with
projections you know if we I've met with
a CFO this morning if the numbers are
they'll have to go a lot higher than
that that becomes a problem a problem
for us that we'll have to go back and
make some decisions and make some
changes in August and in July which is
for a little bit problematic for us to
be making changes in making decisions
and making cuts that so you know
technically we do have a budget we're
going to move forward with planning as
if that's the number that we that we are
going to have to make some reductions
but if the number is larger than that
it's going to be a problem what are the
biggest financial holdups for you that
you see playing out here I'm gonna tell
you following social distancing around
transportation that's going to be a
problem for us
the the cleaning of our schools in
between you know at the end of the day
before making sure that our kids are you
know come back are cleaning and
following the guidelines really looking
at our playgrounds and our students you
know so all of these things that are
really operational that may impact the
safety of our kids is something we're
we're seeing enough an increase in our
numbers and making some decisions around
you know obviously that we've put out
not a request on on the governor's task
force around the PPE s for our students
for our families you know three hundred
twenty thousand students forty two
thousand employees so all of these
requests that we have out there we still
are waiting for some final answers we
talk to a lot of both parents and
teachers and as this school year as the
summer continues as school year
approaches as people are going back to
work they want to know our kids going to
be in school or do they need to plan for
some sort of home learning and changing
their life around you know that's why I
committed to the Board of Trustees that
we will have a we will have a decision
and a recommendation on June 25th
because we need to know and everybody
needs to know you know and as I talked
to my colleagues across the country
where you know as fast as we can end the
year
get graduations and now plan on what
August looks like I felt you know the
end of the month of June you know it's
not ideal it is late but we're still
waiting on some answers so and these are
the things that this is the best that we
can do so by the end of the month we'll
have an answer for our families I mean
you probably have one more question and
then quickly yeah you had at the board
meeting earlier last month an expert
come in and say this was the most
decentralized School District in the
country and that's gonna give you
problems
how big a challenge has have been to get
every school to have the same access to
the same education for its students that
is one and I'm glad you brought that up
I think that's one of the things that
unintended consequences of that law that
I'm really decentralizing when you look
at the learning opportunity for kids
there hasn't been an urban school system
that is so decentralized where they've
seen an improvement of student
achievement so that's something that we
certainly are working on we started last
year with a balanced assessment for all
students you know we're now looking at
you know what do we look at for
instructional material so we're bringing
principals in and teachers to help but
we have to with our mobility rate with
our weather from school to school this
is why we have to have a coherent
curriculum in making their decisions to
that truth to address the challenges in
really looking to focus on student
achievement thanks so much John we have
a Chris Redfern next with channel 5
Chris you have a question we'll come
back to Chris we'll go with a channel 8
Kristen Drummond Kristen iam question
during last week's Board of Trustees
meeting trustee Ford had mentioned
possibly having CCSD be three weeks
behind possibly looking at what other
school districts would be doing and not
being essentially as she called it the
guinea pig do you think it would be wise
to see what other urban school districts
are doing before CST decides to bring
children back you know Chris that's a
great question I've been in contact with
the council great city schools with you
know 74 urban superintendents we meet on
a weekly basis
and we're getting some of the plants and
we're sharing I also see it on the aasa'
which is the National Association for
superintendents I'm on the Cova task
force as a superintendent there so we
are I am constantly receiving
information with our my colleagues
across the country with what with what
districts are doing they're planning to
do and we're sharing our plan they're
sharing you know so we are working
collectively as a whole you know this is
not something that we were planned and
trained to really deal with so we are
working across the country with
everybody to see you know how we're
going to open up school following the
guidelines of the CBC so when you
mentioned that your biggest challenge
would be you know transportation right
now cleaning does that mean you would
possibly try and add maybe more people
to help with cleaning
or elongate ours despite you know
possibly dealing with a budget shortage
you know that that's one of the things
that we're looking at I mean what is if
we're gonna have to clean because
parents said they want to come back to
school and be a you know clean clean
schools our number one number two
priority those are the you know when you
look at that survey that was one of the
most important things for them so we
have to look at what's a facility you
know is it going to take us you know
four hours two hours to clean the school
before our kids use it so so that has an
impact on how we open up school and
where do we go I wanted to clarify you
mentioned I believe it was like 37 or 38
million dollars are you expecting that
not to be in your budget and you're
right now trying to figure out what to
do if you don't have all that money no
yeah
thank you for asking the clarifying
question what we what the board adopted
with making projections when when we've
heard when we made those projections was
looking at the recession from 2008
looking at some of those numbers that's
what we're waiting for to see what that
number is final the final number is
going to be that we have to cut and
that's that's part of the challenge that
we have right now so we're going with
that projection as we as we are opening
school thanks so much Princeton we have
Jeremy chant channel 13 Jeremy do you
have a question yes I do
hello dr. Jarrah Jeremy with channel 13
with the results of that survey one of
the most notable things was a majority
of parents obviously want to go back to
school but did not want to see any more
distance learning per se and of course
with this pandemic that law obviously
have to happen you know how is that
challenging what's you know you're
trying to recommend to the board what
what how measures have that played into
that you know I want to go back and you
know with what was shared also it was to
get an input to provide input for us to
see where engaging the community is you
know not everybody's going to be happy
with a final outcome right I mean I
think that's one of the things
we have to understand but we're going to
do the best we can for our kids
following the guidelines make sure that
that we're healthy and knowing that we
were not ready and we're not because
there has been a limited investment in
professional development in technology
there's a huge digital divide that we
have in this community so all of us
things are going into into our
decision-making process for our schools
in and what schools going to look like
an office
course and in that same survey was also
mentioned about 4,000 students
unfortunately we're not able reached
during the time distance learning was
implemented are there any plans in place
whenever schools reopen to address that
particular area absolutely and one of
the things that we've learned and back
to what you just heard a minute ago
about collaborating with with my
colleagues across the country there's
some school system Tulsa one of the
things that we've learned from Tulsa
they've had some you know they've put a
system in place with social workers that
they're constantly calling it staying
engaged with their families and most
vulnerable community so we put some of
those things in place as well now the
summer and we're going to continue to do
that make sure that you know that we
don't leave anybody out there that we're
not trying to connect with thanks so
much chairman we have Alex with
review-journal
Alex you have a question yes thank you
dr. Jarrah you're working group
discussed eight different options you
know ranging from alternating weeks to
you know days and things like that is
there one option that the district is
currently leaning towards and then in a
second part if the plan is to reopen
school buildings will the district
provide PPE to students as well as staff
so that's a great question and one of
the things that we're looking at do I
favor you know I would love to have all
our kids back and you know from
everybody just but obviously we we have
to look at class size we have to look at
social distancing we have to look at our
teachers one our kids everybody wants to
be back obviously that's that's you know
that's one of the things that we're
working making sure that everybody's
sakes so
you know we're looking at the
feasibility the affordability you know
because if we are to look at putting
kids on a bus and social distancing you
know we how many more buses do we need
can I get buses then we can we you know
put our class sizes are so large when
you look at our 900 square foot
classroom how many kids can I put in the
school in a classroom our buildings and
can so do I work you know I can't tell
you right now which one of my favorites
because it would be unfair I'm gonna be
we're working on a couple of different
models that we will be sharing with the
Board of Trustees on the 25th that's
number one number two was on the PB
those are those are some of the cost
factors that were taken into place that
you know that we provide dbe's for our
students in their stuff sure absolutely
and I'm sorry one more thing if you got
in the pair's act this person is we are
in currently and applying for it and
it's around eighty two million dollars
and that is again that is not - you know
that's one of the things that we're
putting in place we're waiting on what
that number is to cut so then we can
then find ways that we minimize the
impact to our employees thank you thank
you
Jackie Valley with the Nevada
independent do you have a question yes
hi dr. Jarrah my questions about teacher
recruitment and retention
you know most years we see a teacher
shortage anyway
what's that picture looking like this
year and on top of that are you getting
a lot of fears or hesitancy from
teachers who may be in a vulnerable
population okay yeah I know you know the
number it actually was asked at the
State Board meeting and we can get the
exact number out to you but a lot of our
teachers you know the majority of our
teachers said that they're coming back
my current teacher so now what the those
that are in the most vulnerable
population weren't wearing conversations
right now with the county with a you
know about testing in UMC about testing
our employees so we're having some of
these high-level conversations putting a
plan in place to protect them but those
those are factors that we're taking into
place as to you know offering choice of
our employees and our in our and our
students we also have students that are
Matic
fragile as well that we have to also
take into account and find ways to
address so you know those are some of
the things that we're looking at but as
far as as recruiting you know our HR
team is really finding different ways to
recruit our teachers you know through
this process as well which you know as
you know is it's always been a challenge
and this is just odd Stewart this year
and I'm glad you mentioned that the
testing component what do you anticipate
happening when the school year starts do
you think employees and students are
just one group of the other will face
some sort of testing we're having
conversations right now like I said with
the county and one of the things that
you know we've put out there there's
there's testing now but the challenge is
that you know you can get tested today
at 10 o'clock and then be negative and
then be positive at the end of the day
or be positive the next morning so you
know those are the things what is that
ongoing plan so those it you know those
are those discussions that our director
of health and nurses is having with UMC
and with the county and what does that
process look like but you know go get
tested now if you want to know and we're
recommending that if we put that out
there you know I've been working with
our you know with a partners in Southern
Nevada to really you know have that as a
as an option for our employees Thank You
Jackie
we have Sarah with the Las Vegas Sun
Sarah do you have a question um yeah
thank you uh uh did you say when you'll
get more details about the budget no
we're still we're still waiting on the
numbers right now I know that the
governor announced yesterday a special
session you know but we're still waiting
on what that looks like we don't know
what are some of the details about the
budget that you do know right now when I
presented to the ward
you know the 37 to 38 sivan 37 38
million dollar reduction that we
have within our budget at this point
that's as far as I know what we
presented we don't have any other
information that I can share publicly or
with anybody because it's it's it's not
information that I have okay um and then
based on the survey did you get a sense
of how many parents said they're going
to keep their kids at home when the
school new open no we don't have that we
don't have that data but I know that
well you know that could be an option
and that could be a possibility so we're
looking at all those different factors
in order for us to open school thank you
thank you so much Sarah Channel Five's
having some technical difficulties if
they did text me a question and they
were hoping to ask you dr. Jarrah how
you plan to have safety protocols in
place as special education students as
you know could be a little bit different
with that student population
yeah I know that's a great question and
those of you know the fact is that we're
putting in place and again it goes back
to you know the social distance the
medically fragile students and those are
the ones obviously all our kids are
important and we're taking all the
precautions but those are you know the
precautions that we have to take with
our special special needs population
especially medically fragile obviously
the constant cleaning and and then the
social distance is going to be a
challenge but something that we're
working through right now and then
learning from what other districts are
doing I know that the counselor bridge a
school sent us a report you know what
other districts are doing that has been
put together so that collaboration has
been very helpful for us thank you so
much Telemundo do you have a question
see Miss Kucha yeah hola buenos días
gracias por su tiempo hace esto mi
pregunta es y bueno n poquito de lo que
ya hablado piment a Paran español sobre
los resultados de esta encuesta de este
estudio que se hizo que es lo que los
datos que que más interesante ed que
esta esta respuestas si gracias gracias
por la pregunta Toma interesa que todo
mundo quiere que lo Nino
well a Karim Allah Allah well Apollo to
the ante
I think tomorrow Hondo para para la
oportunidad si primero ma che la salud
Aloha idiot la profesora he no lol ah ma
lo más importante por este momento que
es lo que como en Quentin contraste la
participation and este studio less
satisfactory Allah participation see
first
I'll go KKK know anything cuatro
military ponder on service ek well ok
muy interesante he if we I'm gonna
semana si que algo que que vem we al
lado comenzó como Baltazar el CCSD dis
ito escolar estas respuestas no esta
información de lo que ustedes bien de lo
que piensa el público y profesores si se
puede
y hasta Horita que es lo que tienen
hasta el momento de como serie este
regreso a la education
bueno vamos o lo que estamos trabajando
y como vamos a hacer silom hacer con
computadora papel ESO lo que está mejor
achieve a memory todo dia a un dia la
mañana en la tarde es o locate amo ahora
como si el presupuesto para ver como lo
que lo vamos a si lo podemos hacer todo
ESO lo que ahora a very cuando que es lo
que personalmente a jew stedy notado tal
vez en otros distritos escolares tambien
a yellow cape UDA funcionar mejor para
nosotros
si si que todo decir algo de todo los
vamos a tratar como vamos a ser hecho y
y lo que estamos viendo yo amo a poder a
trato de estudiantes y tu sabe SI
seguimos como estamos como el vino esta
Bob acero problema que como vamos a
poder de Lucas contrato étudiante y para
cuando sus adrià esto para cuando se
espera tomar una decisión ye a Quarren
cuando esto el
cuando esto último en cuanto al
pendiente indonesian tienes una pregunta
Univision okay question alright folks
time for one more quick question from
each of you if you can just be prepared
appreciate it and go down the list in
Reverse
Telemundo did you have one more final
question alright so DSP Cortelyou my
pillow
algo más que le gustaría regard O'Hara
en cuanto a los los prepara TiVo's TSS
tannin reales on Dolas giunta's que
estan teniendo el público ba participar
tambien bucegi participant re unions
danos opinion see a venti Cinco
Nishioka see kidding yourself I see more
okay yes
Sarah the Las Vegas Sun did you have one
more final quick question are you
clipping with certain days that schools
might open depending on what you find
out June 25th
I know I think I mean we're shooting for
an August 10th right now you know it all
depends a lot of with a lot of variables
at this point Sarah that we're working
through right now okay thank you thank
you Sarah Jackie Valley one last
question on June 25th so you'll present
the recommendations and then it's up to
the board to approve that if they so
choose
well I think right now I mean you know
here's where we're gonna do the best the
best move forward we're still waiting on
you know obviously the ultimate decision
is with the state of when the schools
were closed by the state chief health
officer for the state of Nevada so
ultimately will the final decision will
be from the State Department Thank You
Jackie Alex with the review-journal yes
so I had a similar question to Jackie so
the process will be you guys will bring
recommendations to the board and the
board will vote to accept them possibly
and then you'll wait on the final word
from the state yeah we yes Alex and Jack
if what you know we'll move forward and
then we'll present to the board and then
obviously then we'll have to if you look
at last week's directive from the
governor you know that the we have to
then submit that to the State Department
as well for them to approve it okay sure
and isn't reopening schools for summer a
part of those considerations no we have
you know right now we made some
decisions about summer school because
you know when the when the
recommendations that we received from
the state last week we already start at
summer school summer school started for
us June 1 so we're not going to change
course as of right now we're still doing
esy because those are most medically
fragile students that we we're going to
still provide that online and then we're
also looking at our credit recovery and
some of the other programs that's going
to stay for now through distance
learning we're looking at
some of some of their recent
recommendation and potentially making
some changes but at this point we're
still moving forward with distance
education for the summer thank you thank
you Alex jeremy chen channel 13 yes real
quick in regards to athletics any plans
that athletic teams are able to access
school facilities during the summer and
owners orders so you know at this point
we're analyzing that I mean because
obviously there was a lot of
restrictions and time and social
distancing so we'll be sharing that with
our coaches and our principals right now
with them in the coming week okay thank
you
Thank You Jeremy Kristen Drummond
Channel 8 dr. John I know as you're
going forward how frustrating is it to
get put all these plans in place but
still not knowing what your budgets
going to be because whatever plans you
put in place they honestly could almost
you just tossed out the window once you
realize what money you have it seems one
of the biggest challenges that I'm
facing is that it's the lack of this is
a lack of knowing what the numbers may
be up and that's part of what what the
challenge is the frustration that I'm
being you know and especially when my
principals in my elementary and middle
school principals are all going home on
Friday you know and that means sots have
to me and all of these different things
that you know when you're opening up the
school in August everybody's going home
you know because they're 11-month
employees the only ones that are
12-month are high school principals so
there's a lot of stress being put on a
lot of folks and we don't have the
numbers right now so we're going on the
30 on the best numbers that we have but
you're right there's potential that you
know that we may have to go back and
revisit so I'm sending my information I
can't wait as you've heard you know from
from earlier questions here our
community wants to know and and that's
why we are doing is superintendent for
Clark County School District I am
sharing with my community here's where
we're going and here's where the best in
that we have today Thank You Kristen
second question Texas to me dr. jar from
Channel five they wanted to know if
there's a certain school district around
the nation or even overseas that we're
using as a model um possibly reopening
something that's worked for them we're
looking at everything you know obviously
you know I mentioned Tulsa they're doing
some things you know miami-dade has go
none of the things that you're looking
at you know Chicago there's a lot of
this variable San Antonio's got some
really good things that they've shared
so we're it's a hodgepodge and then also
we're receiving information from other
other other school systems across the
world so we're you know the team is you
know looking at all the different plans
every night every there's a lot of night
reading but we're looking at everything
to see what fits for CCSD thank you so
much last question John Traynor channel
3 yeah dr. cha review suspended any
administrative contracts or are you
looking at taking pay cuts at the
administrative level no we have not John
we're not looking at you know any of the
other bargaining units in the contracts
why not as other unions across the the
county in the state are trying to do
that to make up for the deficit you know
well obviously we have collective
bargaining you know and that's part of
where something that it's a conversation
that we have again I don't know what the
numbers is you know I think with the 37
million that you know that the 37
million that we have to if we have to
cut I think we're in a good spot because
now we have the Care Act dollars that
would be able to help us you know and
that's where I feel very confident if
that's the number will be it will be
okay this coming year without any
bargaining any any any discussions with
our bargaining units if it's a bigger
number would administrative positions
not not at the teacher level but the
higher level in the school district take
cuts well you know when you're looking
at where already when you look at our
numbers you look at our budget when you
you know as a central office it's not
like we have extra extra extra folks
here in the district office either I
mean you know you look at our budget
that was
to the board there's a hundred and eight
million dollars in schools you know that
from carry-forward from supplies from a
lot of that you know there's so there's
there's there's opportunities to be able
to get to where we need to be without
having to to really make some of these
drastic numbers unless you know as we've
heard some of the questions if we know
and and and I'm being told from what I'm
being told from the state superintendent
that obviously education is a priority
at the state level which is great but I
just need to know what those numbers are
folks thank you so much appreciate your
time dr. Jarrah thank you so much thank
you